happy Super Bowl Sunday papal GL bahir J
Humphrey here what's your name
Pat ho here Pat Hogue has nothing better
to do you Canadian loser yeah he's gonna
be here hanging out having Super Bowl
Sunday with us watching a bunch of
trailer so guys we're gonna be football
don't you have the CFL let's get to it
guys I don't want to yell at you two all
right
we're both understand minorities are
taking over the whites
speaking of minorities sir Marcus yeah
that's true this movie has been getting
a little bit of a controversial
reception towards it but let's just take
this movie on its own merits as we watch
this trailer I'm excited yeah no
politics in my life in general but guys
we're gonna be covering a lot more so
make sure to subscribe click that
notification bus to get notified when
our next reaction is up we know a Super
Bowl tends to drop a lot of things so
keep updated with us anyhow let's get
into this trailer
[Music]
Jason's collie
locked gates of our northern cities
founded in a coordinated attack their
leader fights alongside Alicia
Oh
that characters on the crusties
murderers that's at least I thought they
cannot fight so I will take his place
yes the northern invaders will kill her
when we take the Imperial City take
revenge for my father what's your name
soldier seems like a very personal
village but the water what a teacher I
love how much Chinese everything
[Music]
whoa what the
[Music]
nice ham
[Music]
all right love cow well the fight scenes
in that Eddie Murphy man you know he's
so glad he's reprising a new shoe role
yeah I think the biggest takeaway that I
actually had with this trailer as
opposed to the other ones because it's
carrying over a lot of the same themes
that we've seen from the other ones but
you get a really good look at Jason
scollay here as the villain one of the
villains below they got two right he got
him and you got the witch care her
tag-teaming yeah and it seems like
there's a real personal motivation for
him because in in the in the animated
movie he you know just wanted to conquer
territory Disney baddie and here it
seems like they gave a lot more
attention to detail on flushing his
character out and on top of that the
thing I didn't pick up on before that's
pretty cool considered the fact that you
got like martial arts legendary actors
like Donnie and gently in here who don't
look like they're part of the main play
of the action sequences or the most part
they're gonna face off and have no sense
for the emperor could be fighting it but
why not
the fight scenes look really cool they
kind of remind me a little bit of that
you looping Corey Yuen kind of Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon fighting action
style and that's something I didn't even
think about when it came to the other
trailers but considering the fact that
you are dealing with Asian culture war
battles
yeah you kind of want some cool ass
action fights though I was pretty much
pretty impressed with the way all that
looked yeah yeah I mean Disney always
gets me to a degree with these new
trailers that they put out for these you
know revitalizations of their classics
and I feel like of all of them this one
has a good amount that it could you know
do to justify its existence basically
and so I love that it does look like a
real Chinese epic you know sort of a
Peking Opera sort of thing and it has
that yeah Crouching Tiger that very
traditional and very fluid beautiful
looking artistic fight style as well as
the more like battlefield you know lines
charging at each other sort of stuff so
I really hope that
yeah you know Disney doesn't throw down
on heaviness as much as they do
production design and everything like
that but I hope that this brings a
certain amount of weight that this story
could do because of all their retreads I
feel like this one is potentially
worthwhile well and it's it's like the
the latest kind of Disney films I feel
like are following too much into the
retread territory of like its Lion King
again I mean the beast again and it's
like they worked those films work they
have like a template to follow but Mulan
and all of those films I didn't really
have a touch base for my childhood but
Mulan was one I constantly watched him
repeat and I constantly had an
attachment before to all the changes
they were talking about making of no Mu
Shu it's not gonna be a musical I was
okay with and didn't really have any
trepidation towards because I feel like
especially how the trailers have been
showing it is that they are going more
in service of the culture they're going
more in service of you know it's about
family honor it's about you know nature
it's about matchmaking matchmaking and
it's about like having you know armies
be a representation for the ideology
between the two not just have the bad
guy want to conquer but like what is his
emotional goal
fighting against Mulan against the
family and seeing that Disney is kind of
letting them not just be about you know
good guy comes in fights and the bad
guys have to be stopped it's about honor
it is about kind of what the first Mulan
kind of touched on but it looks like
this one's pushing it forward and
getting rid of the more childish stuff
that doesn't fit in Chinese epics wow
dude thank you so long a return to the
channel that was hey I've been doing
great
it took me eight weeks some solid points
you're making right but it is the one
Disney movie that they have lined up
that I've been pretty excited for
because it feels like admits any
controversy that come in midst any kind
of naysayers going towards it they have
to be the most careful let's treat this
honorably let's be respectful and this
on top of it kinda looks beautiful the
colors really pop and looks beautiful
you're right about that I kind of wonder
because none of the trailers I've put
this on display at all I kind of wonder
if it's gonna be I don't know if like
about a comedy but I think there's
probably gonna be a lot more humor
where's the it works especially because
in the fact of the matter is they're not
they're borrowing from the real-life one
of what movies on but they're also
adapting the disney version and they're
doing this weird splice above marketable
family-friendly exactly so they're doing
a splice of both with that in mind I'm
like well you gotta have some of that
Disney humor right especially when she's
like in the camp and to forget all their
names right offhand people like was
really funny and I kind of want that
humor to still be present there at least
in in that section of the movie I like
if they go heavy I am I'm all for that
at the same time I'm like I don't want
them to entirely lose some of the humor
in it are and it's gonna be yes because
I still think there's some real-life
humor you can sort of joke at with in
terms of the fact that this is a woman
impersonating a man infiltrating an army
even though this is based on a true
story there's still some fun to be had
yeah with that and this was Big Momma's
House would be comedy maybe it would be
really funny so we're on the scale of
pigs mama house is Disney gonna be going
for this one
yeah we're Mar Lawrence is taking over
Eddie Murphy's rules alright guys well
what did you think of this final trailer
for Mulan what are your thoughts on this
film do you think that it'll be one of
the better Disney live-action
adaptations comment below subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bill to get accepted in the reject
nation get a kisser up at yep that's
hilarious
follow pat on social media check us out
on patreon and stardust app and oh yeah
one more thing patron otherday shout out
this one's for Chris lamb off now Chris
swam off actually wanted us to dedicate
his patron of the day shout out to his
good buddy
D'Angelo cuz he just found out D'Angelo
is gonna be a father
Oh give it up give it up for Angela now
D'Angelo I'm gonna give you some
fatherly advice if it's a son you get
him laid right away I'm talking ten
years old if it's a girl chastity belt
you don't want any you know what I mean
so son have fun girl ruin her world
plain and simple you should get that
tattoo just as a reminder so that you
know the parenting advice the real
reject you could follow my blog where I
am gonna give plenty of parent and I'm
not para myself but I'm gonna give a lot
of parenting advice on there and I'm
starting up my own adoption agency to
take care of the unfortunate because
clearly I know what I'm doing
best of luck to you and D Angelo Angelo
is actually my middle name hey see he
knows what he's talking about so in a
way D'Angelo is named after you we have
a lot in common D'Angelo